first confirmed death in Britain from  coronavirus or someone who's tested  positive for coronavirus and we've got a  statement now from the Royal Berkshire  NHS Trust and it says that sadly we can  confirm that an older patient with  underlying health conditions has died  the patient has previously been in and  out of hospital for non coronavirus  reasons but on this occasion was  admitted and last night tested positive  for coronavirus the family has been  informed and our thoughts are with them  at this difficult time  we will not be commenting further they  say and ask that everybody respects the  family's privacy  you